- Make sure that you know what you want
and go for it.
I'm totally like a confident person.
I'll stand up to everybody.
I love to express myself.
I always just focus on the positive side.
♫ When you're gone
♫ The pieces of my heart are missing you
- What's up, Believe Nation?
It's Evan.
My one word is 'believe',
and I believe that you have
the ability to do something special
that can change the planet.
So to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn from the Canadian
singer-songwriter, Avril Lavigne,
and my take on her top
ten rules for success.
Rule number nine is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
(theme music)
- [Interviewer] If you could go back,
like in a time machine,
and speak to you when
you were 15, you know,
what sort of advice
would you give yourself,
knowing what you know now?
- Pretty much the same
advice that I do know,
which is make sure that
you know what you want
and go for it, and
don't let anyone change your mind.
I was always very focused,
and I've always been the type of person
that listens to my gut,
and I think it's important to do that,
to go with your instincts.
I would say that to myself.
And I definitely did do that.
Pretty much everyone that's
working with me gets, like,
what I'm into, and what I like, and stuff,
but if there ever is a situation,
then I'm totally, like,
a confident person.
I'll stand up to everybody
and tell them, like,
"No, I really believe this.
"This is what my gut's telling me."
If there's something that's bugging me,
like I'll totally speak up to it.
Like, speak up about it.
I'm not shy and I'm not going to let ...
It's too risky to let, you know--
This is my life.
I don't want to, like, mess up my career
and so I need to speak up and, like,
tell people what I think.
On Under My Skin I kind
of just went right off
of my tour into writing the record.
And it was done in six months.
I knew how I wanted it to sound,
and how I wanted it to come across.
So, I had to share my vision.
♫ Give up the grudge
♫ (bleep) mouth
♫ Why you got to judge
♫ Everybody but yourself
I feel like this record
is more emotional for me,
you know, it's just, it's deeper, and
I just feel like I was
able to express myself
on a different level.
(Crowd sings "Girlfriend")
(shouts)
Sink in.
I've always been a really carefree spirit.
I've always wanted to just have fun.
And so, I feel like I
love to express myself,
and to be emotional, and ...
And I feel like, on camera,
and stuff like that,
I feel like that's what I do,
and I was born with wanting to do this.
I guess the only thing is,
when I was younger, you know,
having to deal with, "Why
don't people like me?"
You know, I didn't do anything to them.
That would have been the struggle,
I guess, if anything.
But that is just how it is.
And there's nothing you can do about it.
So I always just focus
on the positive side,
and the positive side
is a very large side.
I'm really focused.
I'm here, I'm in Hollywood,
because I have a job.
I'm a songwriter, I'm a
singer, I'm a performer.
I spend the majority of my time
on the road, touring.
And you know something?
That was my dream.
I worked really hard for it.
So you know, I've just--
I'm really dedicated to my career, and
also expanding into other
things, like Abbey Dawn.
Yeah, I have passion for music,
and now my music career has blown up,
it's done really well.
And now I have, like, great opportunities,
I'm in a really situation,
I'm very thankful.
And I want to do other
things, too, you know.
I'm looking for a lead role
in a movie, and that'll be,
you know, that'll be a challenge,
which is what I like.
And I want to do other things, you know,
The clothing line, that's like, very me.
Like, my style.
Like, do other things,
and create, like ...
I just, I want to do a million things.
I think, like for me,
I'm a young free spirit,
like I work hard, but I also like
to not take things too seriously,
and really, like, coming back to the song,
it's just about, like, you know,
it doesn't matter what age you are.
And, you know, it's all about,
it's your state of mind.
So I think, you know, a lot of times
it's an approach, it's one thing.
And yeah, I think it's positive.
I always tweet my fans, and ask them,
"Hey, like what song do you
guys like on the record?
"And how do you feel about
"these two songs being the single?"
And I get to read their feedback,
and be connected with
the fans through Twitter,
and it's really cool.
'Cause I can have that
personal relationship,
and we can kind of communicate that way.
And it's nice for me.
I just think it's really important
to listen to yourself, and to be yourself,
and believe in yourself,
and whatever it is,
anything that you're trying to do.
- Absolutely, that applies
to life in general.
- Yeah, in general, you got to be happy.
Life's short. (crowd cheers, applauds)
- Good advice from Avril Lavigne.
- I have to make music for myself.
And I have to go with,
in the direction that I'm
feeling, and that I want.
Because I, you know I can't do something
that I don't want to do,
and then not be happy.
It's all about being happy.
And that's always been
my message to my fans,
is just, "Be who you
are, know who you are,
"and go after it."
♫ And the clothes you left
♫ They lie on the floor
♫ And they smell just like you
♫ I love the things that you do, oh
♫ When you walk away
♫ I count the steps that you take
♫ And do you see how
much I need you right now
♫ When you're gone
♫ The pieces of my heart are missing you
♫ The face I came to know is missing too
♫ When you're gone
♫ The words I need to hear
♫ To always get me through the day
♫ And make it okay
♫ And I miss you
♫ We were made for each other
♫ Out here forever
♫ And I know we were
♫ Yeah, yeah
♫ All I ever wanted was for you to know
♫ Everything I do I give my heart and soul
♫ I can hardly breathe
♫ I need to feel you here with me
♫ Yeah
♫ When you're gone
♫ The pieces of my heart are missing you
♫ The face I came to know is missing too
♫ When you're gone
♫ The words I need to hear
♫ To always get me through the day
♫ And make it okay
♫ I miss you
♫ Oh, oh
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because Luka on my team,
who's in the comments a lot,
and does some of the
research for the videos,
asked me to.
She's his favorite singer,
so this one's for you, Luka.
If there's someone you'd like to vote on
for the next top 10,
check out the link in the description,
and go and have your say.
Finally, want to give a quick
shout-out to Kemo Tedajo.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and taking
that amazing picture
with the book at the Eiffel Tower.
I should have done that
when I went to Paris.
Anyway, thank you so
much for your support.
I really appreciate it, and I'm so glad
you enjoyed the book.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- Well, I think because I was so popular
when I came out, there was a lot of people
who were like, "Oh, she's fake."
And, "She's not real."
And that to me was weird,
because I felt like,
I am the one who's real.
If anyone would have told me how to be,
they would have said,
"Dress nicer. Talk better.
"Like, don't swear. Like, be ..."
You know what I mean?
They would have turned me into
someone nicer, like, I don't know,
a Hilary Duff or something.
I think she--
I'm not dissing her in any way, but
someone more like that, I think.
And I was just very myself,
and different from everyone.
And so to hear people say that I was fake,
I was like, (raspberry) "No I'm not.
"I'm like the most real thing ever.
"I'm like myself."
I've grown in many ways on my new album,
Goodby Lullaby.
I wrote half the record by myself,
I produced two songs.
I played more instruments on it.
And whereas I typically, usually just,
like, co-write all my music,
this time I pushed myself,
I produced, and ...
And this is also my fourth world tour.
So I feel that with every album,
and with every tour, I'm constantly
learning more through my experiences.
♫ Nothing you can say
♫ Nothing you can do
♫ There's no other way
♫ When it comes to the truth
♫ Keep holding on
♫ 'Cause you know we'll make it through
♫ We'll make it through
♫ Hear me when I say
♫ When I say I believe
♫ Nothing's going to change
♫ Nothing's going to change destiny
♫ Whatever's meant to be
will work out perfectly
♫ Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
♫ La da da da
♫ Keep holding on
♫ 'Cause you know we'll make it through
♫ We'll make it through
♫ Just stay strong
♫ 'Cause you know I'm here for you
♫ I'm here for you.
♫ Nothing you can say
♫ Nothing you can do
♫ There's no other way
♫ When it comes to the truth
♫ Keep holding on
♫ 'Cause you know we'll make it through
♫ Oh oh
♫ Oh
♫ Keep holding on
♫ Oh oh
♫ Nothing you can say
♫ Nothing you can do
♫ There's no other way
♫ When it comes to the truth
♫ Keep holding on
♫ 'Cause you know we'll make it through
♫ I bow to you
(crowd cheers wildly)